Hi I’m Kamina Vincent, and I am the producer
at Mountains Studio
based in Melbourne, Australia.
For me, this program has been very eye opening.
And seeing how other countries
are making games and collaborating
has been really great.
I think for me, this program is really important
because it does bring very different teams together
and people can share what they’ve learnt
and help build each other up.
It’s great to see this support network
that has been built here.
I would highly recommend this
accelerator program to indie developers.
What you get from something like this
is knowledge that you just can’t pick up on your own.
It’s accelerated,
you get a vast amount of information all at once.
You get access to other developers,
you build a community and a network around you
that you can then lean on,
and I feel that’s one of the biggest things
that we need in game development.
it’s this sharing and support
and this is the program that really does fast track that.